Speaker 1: I love segments like this.
Next one today, we're going to go through
some examples of lying with graphs.
I've told you before all the different ways
you can lie with statistics.
There's a book I've recommended many times.
It's called How to Lie with Statistics by
Daryl Huff.
Not a new book, but a very important book
to understand in the book.
It talks about sampling bias or selectively
choosing.
When you say average choosing mean median
or mode, depending on which is most convenient
for the point you're trying to make.
It talks about post hoc ergo propter hoc.
All of this stuff is in the book, but one
of the chapters is called The Gee Whiz Graph.
It's a way to lie with graphs and a classic
in line with graphs specifically is truncating
the Y axis or sometimes the X axis.
The Y axis is the vertical axis on a graph.
So think through just a general example and
then we'll look at what Fox News did in the
last few days.
Imagine I want to give you the impression
that the temperature just skyrocketed when
it really didn't.
Now, in the northeast of the United States,
over the course of a year, there's a really
broad temperature range.
You know, in winter, there's some days where
it's minus five Fahrenheit.
Sometimes you'll get a minus 10 Fahrenheit
day in some parts of the northeast.
And yet in the summer, it can be like 100
hundred degrees Fahrenheit on a really hot
day during a heat wave.
So that's a big range, minus 10 to 100.
If one day it's 72 degrees and the next day
it's 75 degrees, that's not a big change.
When you think about sometimes it's minus
10, sometimes it's 100.
But if I plot the 72 and 75 degree days and
really shorten that y axis, so the chart starts
at 70 degrees and ends at 80 degrees, that
three degree change between 72 and 75 will
look absolutely huge.
So that gets us to Fox News these last few
days.
And we have multiple examples here the other
day in one of his segments about how the United
States is, I guess, going down the tubes because
not enough people are religious anymore.
Tucker Carlson, put up this graph, which we're
putting up on the screen, which shows the
percentage of Christians in the U.S. in 2009
and the percentage of Christians in the U.S.
in 2019.
And if you look at these yellow bars, that
looks like a big decline.
But if you look at the y axis, you see that
this only starts at 58 percent and ends at
78 percent.
Now, of course, anywhere from zero to 100
percent of Americans could identify as Christian.
That's the range.
But the chart makes the decline look huge
by only showing you the scale, 58 to 78.
Now, Christianity is in decline of religiosity,
is in decline in the United States, but it's
not nearly as dramatic as this chart makes
it look to the untrained eye.
Now, here's one other example.
This is not truncating the y axis.
It's sort of shortening the time horizon,
kind of like shortening the x axis in this
case.
This was on the news side of Fox News, not
opinion.
Bret Bhaya, news man Bret Bayer showed graphs
that make it look like the cost of oil and
gas is just way, way up under Joe Biden.
So they showed this graph of oil prices and
it shows that oil and gas sure seem to have
been really low in 2020 under Trump and then,
boom, skyrocketing under Joe Biden.
But the issue is it only looks at twenty nineteen
through what we have so far of twenty twenty
one.
Then Bret shows this graph of gas prices,
which also shows only 2019 to 2021, and it
looks like gas prices went down in 2020 and
then exploded in twenty twenty one under Joe
Biden.
Now this is deceptive for two reasons.
The first is the pandemic.
The pandemic hit and cratered demand for oil
and gas since people stopped traveling.
And then the recovery started.
And so demand went up and prices started going
up.
That's one reason why it's deceptive.
That's a qualitative reason.
But quantitatively, the.
This is really deceptive because oil prices
have not.
Oil prices have been going up for about seven
years, but they are still historically not
very high.
When you zoom out and you look at a chart
of oil prices that goes back to like 1995
or so, you very quickly see that prices skyrocketed
around 2007 and then came down and then up
in 2012 and then came down.
And now they're roughly at a seven year high
that started about seven years ago.
It is not a Joe Biden thing.
So when you zoom out, you see oil prices are
nowhere near record highs.
And number two, they've been on an increasing
trend that is seven years old now, not this
year under Biden, very similar with natural
gas.
You zoom out to 1995, you see gas prices were
higher in 2001 and 2006 and 2009.
And, yes, they're up again now, extremely
deceptive.
Always look at the labels on the acces.
This is stuff every 12 year old should be
taught.
And if we started teaching this one when kids
were 12, way fewer people would fall for it.
On Fox News.
We'll have these graphs and more examples
on our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show.